I'm Rick Lifton the president of the
Rockefeller University and I'm thrilled
to have the chance to welcome you to our
campus this morning we're grateful that
so many of you have come from far and
wide to be part of this impressive
gathering based on the attendees in the
ambitious agenda for the meeting I'm
sure this is going to be an exciting two
days here at Rockefeller we share your
commitment and passion for increasing
the public's awareness and understanding
and appreciation for the scientific
method and for expanding awareness of
the vital roles that science plays in
our society I trust that the network and
community that you'll be building here
through this terrific conference will
play an important role in your future
endeavors and we're honored to have you
here at the University for the next two
days in an era in which the objective
reality of truth and facts and the
ability to appropriately weigh the
strength of evidence seems under siege
on a daily basis in our society I
believe no effort is more important than
educating the public about the methods
by which we have come to understand the
world around us and the benefits that
that knowledge has brought to our global
society this rightfully begins in K
through 12 education inspiring children
about the wonders of nature and the
methods by which we achieve new insights
into its workings
this should continue throughout life
this is why I'm particularly delighted
to welcome you all to campus today I
moved here to Rockefeller from Yale in
2016 and I can tell you that one of the
many factors that impressed me here was
a university strong commitment to
engaging the public in science we're
enormous ly proud of our scientific
culture here at Rockefeller and of our
efforts to spark interest public
interest in an awareness of the key role
of science in advancing health and
societal goals just two nights ago we
had an overflow crowd of more than 400
lay people at Caspari auditorium just
across the walkway for the presentation
of the Pearl Meister green guard award
the world's most prominent award for
women in biomedical science - the CRISPR
pioneer Jennifer Doudna that was
followed yesterday
yesterday morning by more than a hundred
and fifty participants in our women in
science program who attended Jennifer's
public science lecture at 8 a.m. here in
this room with an overflow crowd events
like these increase awareness of the
importance of society in our city and
around the world we do a dozen events
like this for adults on campus each year
including our women in science our
parents in science and insight lecture
series on a k-12 front we're immensely
proud of the rock edu outreach program
led by Jeanne Garbarino that brings New
York City middle school students high
school students and stem teachers to
campus to engage in hands-on science
curricula with opportunities for deeper
lab experience and summer science
programs for students who catch the
science bug two other of my favorite
events of the year are talking science
program that brings high school students
to campus to learn more about science
discovery from some of the world's great
scientists via interactive presentations
and hands-on demonstrations and our
science Saturday program which brings a
thousand area area middle schoolers and
their parents to campus for a remarkable
day of hands-on science with more than
30 engaging science stations directed by
working scientists from Rockefeller and
colleagues from our sister institutions
across the city this mission also
extends to educating our government
officials about the importance of public
support for science as a public good
early in my term here one of our
trustees bill Ford and I had the
opportunity to organize a small group of
scientific leaders from academia and
industry to meet on two occasions with
the new Trump administration which had
early on proposed a 20% reduction in the
funding for biomedical research in order
to educate them about the vital impact
that public support for biomedical
science has had on the dramatic increase
in healthy lifespan over the last
century as well as on the nation's
economic vitality it's been gratifying
that with the strong support for
Congress the NIH budget has in fact
increased 20% over the last three years
commitment engagement are critical
before I turn things over to Jeannie I
also want to take a moment just to tell
you a little bit about Rockefeller
University and give you some context for
where you are meeting today Rockefeller
is a remarkable home for science was
founded in 1901 with its core mission
science for the benefit of humanity it's
dedicated to the research and graduate
education and biomedical and related
Natural Sciences over the last century
Rockefeller scientists have sought to
solve the deepest questions in
biomedical science with the knowledge
that that fundamental understanding of
life processes and disease are the
surest path to preventing diagnosing and
effectively treating human disease and
along the way they have made
transformative breakthroughs for example
Avery's classic experiments with
pneumococcus demonstrating that DNA is
the chemical of heredity those
experiments were performed about a
hundred and fifty yards to the south
from here on the Rockefeller campus in
1944 and there are many other reminyl
discoveries of that ilk although we only
have 80 faculty here on campus we're
home to some of the world's most amazing
scientists including 39 members of the
National Academy of scientists 14 Howard
Hughes Medical Institute investigators a
few weeks after my arrival here in 2016
Charlie Rice received the Lasker Award
for his discoveries about the hepatitis
C virus that led to the development of a
cure for this disease that affects 3
million Americans and a hundred and
seventy million people worldwide at this
time last year Mike Young had just been
announced as the winner of the Nobel
Prize in medicine for his discovery of
the mechanisms of circadian rhythms that
link our sleep/wake cycle feeding and
behavior to the Earth's 24-hour
day/night cycle and just two weeks ago
David Alice was presented with the
Lasker Award for his discovery of the
role of histone modification in
eukaryotic gene regulation an amazing 25
of the 250 professors in our history
have won the Nobel Prize in medicine or
chemistry our community of just over
2,000 people includes
students postdocs and administrative
staff and our clarity of mission
I think permeates through the entire
community and as a consequence a
remarkable number of community members
participate annually in our Rock edu
science outreach activities so I want to
thank Jeanne and her co-organizers
Nicole white a--which of Northwestern
Edwin Lee of st. Joseph's University
Teresa Evans of UTSA Health and Science
Center at San Antonio and our colleagues
from the American Society for
biochemistry and molecular biology for
putting together this week's program I
also want to thank the supporters force
I out 18 the Simons Foundation the Rita
Allen foundation HHMI Tangled Bank
Studios the Pinkerton Foundation and the
National Alliance for broader impacts
your endorsement of this event are
especially meaningful and I also want to
thank our incredible event planning team
for all their logistical support and all
this brings me back to Jeanne Garbarino
it's now my pleasure to introduce Jeanne
who joined Rockefeller in 2008 as a
postdoctoral fellow in the laboratory of
Jan Breslow whose lab was the laboratory
of biochemical genetics and metabolism
in 2012 Jeanne took the helm of our
outreach program and in this role she
has been able to draw upon her passion
for both scientific research and for
STEM education and has just done a
remarkable job
this exceptional rock edu science
outreach program that Jeanne and her
team have built has emerged as the
cornerstone for Rockefellers community
outreach efforts and we're very proud of
her accomplishments and privileged to
have her here at the University and
we're so grateful for all the work that
she has done to turn rock edu into the
visionary program that it is today so
please join me now in welcoming Jeanne
to the program and thank you all for
your efforts to advance the
understanding of science in our society
I'm sure you'll have a productive
meeting welcome thank you
hi good morning thanks Rick for the
introduction and good morning to
everybody thank you for joining us today
I don't memorize very well so I am going
to read so as Rick mentioned I am Jeanne
and I have the pleasure of serving as
director of rocky to use science
outreach and I'm also a member of the
Outreach Committee for ASB MB and so
together we are pleased to welcome you
to your meeting Scioto 18 so many of you
have already put a lot of work into
making this meeting what it is today
and you shared your valuable insights
through the preparatory work and we'll
get into more detail as to what you
actually said through that work but I do
want to point out one of the overarching
themes and many of you have stated over
and over that one of the goals of
science outreach is to reveal the actual
process of science instead of science
being presented as this shiny new
product right and so you know that the
process of science is the foundation of
this is sort of built on this concept of
iteration and failure right and so
failure for us is a really good thing
because we get to learn from it and we
get to iterate upon it and is with this
philosophy that we present to you this
unconference from my understanding the
format that we are using for SCI out 18
is actually very unique I am Not sure
that there's been a conference like this
and at least something that I've been
exposed to and so I want to say to you
with full transparency and in the spirit
of the process of science that I am not
sure that this is the right way to go
about this but I tell you what we've
been doing in the past is not working so
let's iterate right and so last night
someone asked me how I know this meeting
is successful and this is a valid
question because we are spending a huge
amount of time
this morning to really tackle the
question of metrics but my ansel my
answer to that question right now as
we're sitting is is very simple how I am
measuring success of this meeting is you
showed up oh my god let's just start
there right so this meeting represents
our collective call to build a stronger
science outreach infrastructure
regardless of how you were approaching
science outreach in your context we are
not convening over these next two days
to focus on semantics okay so I can't
really tell you what this conference is
but I can tell you what this conference
is not right we're not gonna argue about
what the definition is of outreach we're
not gonna argue about you know what the
set of best practices are for outreach
because I don't fully believe that we
can come up with a single definition or
a single set of best practices because
we all come from these different
locations and have different contexts
and different value systems right and so
there's no one right way to do outreach
however based on your input both in the
prep work and the video submissions
there are some unifying philosophies for
science outreach and I'm not gonna stand
up here and tell you what those unifying
philosophies are I'm gonna let you all
tell you what is science outreach
anyways science outreach means meeting
people where they are I think that
science outreach is a way to connect
people to research and to the world
around them so in universities and
institutions that hold knowledge and
expertise are trying to get beyond their
walls science outreach means more than
just teaching people about science it
means finding out what people want I
need I'm finding a way that science can
help them get that science outreach is
super rewarding science outreach is a
space for everyone to grow community
members whether it's youth parents
teachers retirees college students
scientist health professionals everyone
is inspired outreach is about
communication about education working
collaboratively with our university
faculty undergraduate and graduate
students
and ensuring that their involvement is
aligned with their own personal goals at
its best science outreach is a two-way
street it's a conversation between
scientists and the non scientific public
or even sometimes between scientists
from different areas it's not just
having a degree and being in an academic
institution anymore that gives you the
idea of being an expert in something I
think that science outreach s at its
best when it's truly a collaboration
between partners universities k-12
schools nonprofits and corporations all
working towards the same goal I think
the best science outreach comes when
people walk away with something they can
use finding ways to make science fun and
not feel like learning at all it doesn't
look like a lecture or a classroom
it looks like an authentic and dynamic
interaction between people sometimes
messy it definitely should be hands-on
and it should be accessible so that
everyone can see themselves in the
process science outreach is at its best
when you can see participants connect
what was previously disparate ideas and
understand that in that moment when
their lightbulb goes on and leave the
experiences have broadened the worldview
whether they pursue a career in stem or
not is not the measure of success but
whether they have the opportunity to
decide for themselves if they are
interested in the lifetime stem rather
than through the circumstances of their
socio-economic background race gender
geographic location or other aspects of
their identity and community the best
science outreach not only humanizes the
scientists for the public that they're
interacting with but it also tells the
public that I could be part of science
people who look like me people who sound
like me people with my background our
scientists our engineers our
technologists and mathematicians
ODT are each ACH his lessons learned
told with a straight face o is for own
put it on the throne take it shape it
make it in the study you you know that
means unique make sure you stand out to
make interest piqued T that's easy it
stands for teach except you got to make
sure not to preach or make it real with
tangible appeal
so it's an experience that anyone can
feel e you have to evaluate to measure
your successful better your break hey I
say adopt adapt because borrowing
shouldn't be a handicap see of course
for communication the only way to avoid
stagnation and H for the hats help and
have to have nots because where you're
born is just a drawing a lot outreach
sons are like on all the Miss spots and
use the sciences the pencil to connect
the dots
[Applause]
[Laughter]
thanks Jeff if you submitted it I'm
putting it up okay getting zooming back
in okay so we are in an at an inflection
point as the value and necessity of
science outreach becomes fully realized
both in terms of societal impact and as
a means to gain broad support of
scientific research through funding
policy or other relevant avenues we hope
that out of this meeting comes a new
clarity around science outreach both as
a field and as a practice that can be
shared more broadly through a variety of
platforms and channels many of which are
honestly TBD we're gonna see what
happens right so our hope is that
everyone leaves diode 18 energized
inspired and committed to maintaining
and dare I say adding to the momentum
that we anticipate will come out of this
meeting you might have noticed that the
whoops hold on you may have noticed that
the SIA
18 logo is a type of network technically
this is a mycelium trace and we love my
cilia at rocky to you and we think that
is an amazing analogy for science
outreach and here's why firstly it's a
pretty badass organism and it is able to
get into the environment and sense what
the environment around it needs and what
it has and work with that environment to
sort of grow out and connect things
right so I think that's a really great
analogy for science outreach
additionally it it serves as this
information superhighway underneath the
ground that is connecting you know the
things that we see the trees and such
and without this network trees would not
grow as tall as they grow right it is
essential so I think about mycelium as
as this sort of or science outreach as
the sort of mycelium of science right we
are connecting scientists we're
connecting communities and we're
allowing things to grow and that's why
we chose to use this as our as our
logo so thanks to Nika for making it
I'll give her a shout out more
officially in a second so speaking of
our community we are I just want to get
into a little bit of housekeeping we are
asking you to adhere to a few important
guidelines firstly and I think it's
really goes without saying that please
be aware and adhere to our code of
conduct and you can read this in full on
our site at sie out 18 org and at this
unconference everyone has a seat at the
table we're here to learn from each
other we invite you to add your
perspective when you have a learned
experience to share and invite you to
respectfully listen when you have an
opportunity to learn and I have to say I
am a super extrovert and so I try to
like pay attention to how much time I'm
holding the conch which sometimes is
more than I should so I ask all of you
to also be mindful of the time a the
amount of time that you are holding the
concha make sure everybody has a chance
to sort of say their say and if you
witness someone not getting enough time
or sort of being overpowered by someone
else I invite you all to to say
something about it and stick up for that
person okay so more logistics there is a
set of tables under the chairs outside
where we have the atrium there are a set
of rectangular tables we invite you to
put any kind of material from your
programs that you want to share with the
group out on that on that table and also
there are no concurrent sessions
everyone will be moving through the day
together we are adopting this
unconference philosophy and through your
input we've assembled this agenda based
on what you wanted to talk about and
this will consist of lightning talks
presented by members of our fabulous
community that will set the stage for
deeper table level discussions and
workshopping
lightning talks will take place here in
this room and table level work will take
place out in the atrium and then lunch
will take place in the Faculty Club
where we joined last night I also want
to mention for anybody who's nursing and
would like to pump but not miss anything
we have a situation set up in the rocky
View classroom so just making that so
you you can zoom and see what's
happening here
while also
making food for your child which is
important kids need to eat apparently
during our table level work each table
will have a dedicated facilitator and we
have a bunch of templates and we ask
that you are just filling that template
with whatever words you want to put onto
that just do it a little bit legibly so
that we can make sense of it but please
put as much as you can onto those
templates so they can really understand
where you're coming from and to sit at
all of your tables each of you received
four little cards in your bag and your
and feel free to sort of sit at the
table that matches that card that's sort
of our way to loosely get you guys to
separate and network with people you may
not know we invite this also the purpose
one of the purposes of this meeting is
to get people to network with with each
other and we invite you to do so at any
point in time during this conference
however if there is a table level
discussion going on in order to not
derail the conversations we've set up
some spaces sort of on the other side
for you to go and have these quiet
conversations with whoever you want to
sort of you know take over the world
with and just so that we don't interrupt
the flow I'm totally not even advancing
here we are okay so there are four table
little level discussions and I already
told you about the cards and the
templates all right les Oh another thing
is we are providing you with an
opportunity to share your honest
thoughts and experiences with science
outreach through our video confessionals
and so Julie Nadel where are you Julie
there she is right there she is going to
be handling the sort of signups for that
in this video will be used as one of the
outputs of the meeting and is intended
to promote this meeting and the
community of practice that we're
building and you can find it it's in the
lounge in the rock edu lab i'm also want
to take a little bit of time to
front-load the thank-yous at this
meeting in case we all get so crazy and
busy that I don't get a chance to do
that if this meeting would not be
possible without the help of some major
teamwork and first as you are all aware
we have done our best to minimize the
cost of attendance for this meeting and
I
we have set a very high bar for reducing
financial barriers to participation and
so I'd like to thank our funders for
providing this opportunity I will
particularly like to thank Greg from
science sandbox at the Science
Foundation for believing in this effort
and for letting me drive this thing
so thanks and all the help that he Jill
John and Sam has provided and rallying
other funders to ensure that we can
maximize attendance from community
representatives so thank you to science
sandbox HHMI Tangled Bank Studios Rita
Island Foundation the Pinkerton
Foundation ASB MB and the National
Alliance for broader impacts I would
also like to point out that early
aspects of this meeting were shaped by
Jeff Jeff is actually the one who put in
the proposal to ASB and beats you allow
us to do this so thanks Jeff for doing
that she's not here today she couldn't
make it but I also want to thank Boyana
conforte because she was the one who sat
me down was like you can't do this
unless you are making it as low-cost as
possible and so without her sort of
saying like don't do it or don't do it
like you know do it do it big or don't I
wouldn't have even sort of thought that
this is something that we should do so I
appreciate her in input
she sure for a number of very wise and
insights I've been sort of talking with
him throughout the planning process I
mean like is this okay and so he's been
really really helpful and Meg groom who
helps you identify and hone the major
themes we initially proposed for this
meeting and it only cost me a caipirinha
all right - kai barriness but all right
not counting and to the folks who have
been working behind the scenes so our
side out planning committee does that
does this get weird because I thought it
was great he's good
okay but I'm also a little weird right I
know well this is actually one of the
outputs if we can do this in this room
by Friday it's successful right so thank
you Edwin Danielle and Nikki for
everything I'm so excited to be working
with you here I also want to talk about
our facilitation team so these are the
people that are gonna be sitting at the
table so grant Maria Andrea Annie Kate
Devin Becky Christine Sara Christina
Riley at Sonali and Bri thank you for
the work that you're putting into this
and the rock edu team particularly so
Dallas and us and particularly Nika and
Doug Doug is the the money guy so he's
gonna you know make sure and he got you
your hotel so he's a lot of work and
nico designed these beautiful beautiful
things for us this io tall the SIOP
branding and to our student interns lat
tiga and Ivan who stuffed all your bags
prepared all the things so made the
videos and oh this is our reader team I
put facilitation team but this is the
people that read your prep work so thank
you to the people here who who made that
happen as well and helped us at the
agenda okay I think did I get everybody
did I miss anybody
oh thank well thank you for showing up
that's also thank you so okay so the
first thing that we let's just get into
this right the first thing that we're
gonna tackle is metrics and when I say
metrics what is the first thing that
comes to your mind shout something out
numbers what else what is it crass Oh
question yeah
so my answer to that it was like um many
questions little answers you know so so
let's just tackle this head-on right in
this first round of lightning talks will
begin with bringing to light some of the
hard questions around science outreach
that we have all undoubtedly asked
ourselves we will then begin to zoom in
and think about some practical ways of
planning our initiatives to incorporate
metrics from the start as well as proof
of concept ideas around metrics we will
then end with some insights on the state
of evaluation outside of our field keep
in mind that the Lightning speakers will
be hard timed we will do our best to
accommodate a question or two but we ask
that you save them for the end so that
we
you can keep things going
you